this is the only route into agalia
the town at the heart of a war between
two cartels in michoacan southwest
mexico
no journalists have been here since the
jalisco new generation cartel
advanced to take the land around it
we've been told to take this dirt track
over the mountains to get in but it's
not simple
we've just seen in quick succession a
checkpoint that we had to pass through
with
armed guys by the side of the road a
burnt out
truck and then the letters uh the
initials of the jalisco new generation
cartel actually scrawled on the road
itself
there's no real doubt about whose
territory we're in
when we pass the second checkpoint they
want to talk to us
we don't have any necessity to rob we're
drug traffickers
it's true that we're in a fight to
struggle but we're fighting for the
rights of each of us
and for the people
they're on a propaganda push to go with
their advance into this territory
they say they'll let through civilians
who dare to travel
finally we make it to the town they're
fighting for agaliya
on the outskirts it looks like a ghost
town
it might well be one soon thousands have
fled the violence and isolation here
those left have no one to help them we
didn't see a single policeman on our way
or a soldier despite the fact the army
actually has a barracks in the town
residents say they rarely patrol
near the center are signs of life la
paria taqueria
has been serving the village for two
decades but maria contreras
says it's hard to keep it going
it's affecting us a lot everything's got
more expensive
it's really hard to bring in supplies
that's because the main road to the
nearest city
of patsyngan has been closed by another
group carteles unidos
they're fighting the jalisco cartel and
have the area under siege
petrol has to be smuggled in the garage
is out of action
gas is scarce so is medicine and bottled
water
farmers say they can't get their crops
or cattle to market
and the siege has had other costs when
daniela and gabriella's granddad had a
burst stomach ulcer
they couldn't get him to the hospital on
the other side the blockade
he died i felt so helpless because we
couldn't do anything it was out of our
hands
and angry too it's not right that we're
living like this
and he wasn't the only one at the same
time a lady had a miscarriage because
she was trying to get to the hospital
and couldn't we heard more stories
townspeople killed in the crossfire
between the cartels on the road
or in the town itself there's a nightly
soundtrack here
you can probably hear that that's the
sound of gunfire we're just outside of
the village church
night has only just fallen and they've
started shooting here
and where are the authorities absent say
the town's people
until a surprise visit by the governor
last week just as election season began
but when a teacher dared to protest to
him he did this
it enraged many in agalia when we
visited
they gathered to demand one thing
number one free transit on the road from
aguilia
to apating and security for those
traveling
the state security minister also came by
while we were visiting to promise just
that
but he didn't talk to the people of
agalia instead he held a press
conference outside the town
the media he brought with him we joined
them
and i asked him repeatedly if he was
aware of the criminal checkpoints
well if you tell me where if you pass me
the coordinates when we finish
he denied knowing of them the next day
we tried to leave passing burnt out
empty towns
a sign perhaps of agolia's future but we
couldn't get through to a passing game
it's not even 24 hours since the
secretary of public security came down
this road and said that it was now
open and there would be free transit we
just tried to get down it
we've already heard that it's blocked so
we're having to go back down to agalia
eventually the police filled in the
trench that one of the gangs had dug
across
it that night the criminals dug it out
again
the highways closed once more the siege
and suffering continues
john holman al jazeera agalia